so the CEO of the e-cigarette jewel
issued an apology to parents saying that
he's gonna go out of his way to one he
took down all the social media accounts
for jewel and he's not gonna advertise
geared towards children anymore okay
after he made all his millions yeah he's
saying that he feels terrible because he
himself has a 16 year old child and he
can empathize with parents who sees that
their kids are using his products he
says that it wasn't meant for kids but
he can see why with advertisements that
they use with like young 20 year olds
using the jewel products how and how
easily just area right I would assume
he's that they've been jewels got bought
out I'm not really made it is is vaping
is vaping considered as bad that was
cigarettes can we now bring it up chin
it's it's not good it's definitely not
good it's also really early for people
to find like a good study on it but it
doesn't seem like it's leading to great
places because you can control how much
nicotine you put into your ellic and a
lot of kids are using liquids with a lot
of nicotine in it and just running
through them but it is less harmful than
smoking so I would imagine you know they
heat the nicotine I mean that's you know
yeah you can't no don't say it's less
harmful because you read a [ __ ] blog
but well but it is that because when I
set my tracker opposite I've heard exact
opposite from people that are in the
vape business but when you when you when
you heat the tobacco I think you get
more chemicals right so you're inhaling
the smoke and all the chemicals whereas
vape is actually this is such bro
science no it's not
I've read about it me too but it's not
anybody here anybody and we actually
have to sit down with okay but the board
here it's saying that it's kind of also
saying it's all about the one article
know there's a articles for and yeah
they say no one really it's not both we
don't know but I don't know I'm stuffy
I'm telling you they don't know but like
legit businesses are like no no no
because they're gonna be in trouble yeah
cuz some people who on the other side of
it say it's as bad as smoking entire
pack of cigarettes a day really yes and
some go well no because the filter
system is different but they
hasn't been a long extensive research on
it I mean neither one is good
yeah neither one's good we know
nicotine's not good for you though it's
less that it's the apparently the all
the other chemicals that come with it
it's huge though cuz you gotta figure
the heavy metals nickel 10 lead but but
you gotta figure that the tobacco
industry went I people like their hip to
cigarettes no one's really smoking
cigarettes specially Millennials it's
almost completely gone we have come up
with something so they came up with this
and they're not exactly the best people
the tobacco but here's as easier as
biggest threat to public health maybe
this the increased popularity of vaping
may renormalize smoking which is decline
for years Wow smoke is still the leading
preventable cause of death that's
responsible for four hundred and eighty
thousand Americans damn check this out
vaping is the most common form of
tobacco used by kids and teens I see it
everywhere you've seen everywhere you
know and they mark it to teens with the
with the the delicious flavors so do you
walk by it smells fantastic
mmm yeah but I see I see it on both
sides no I'm tired I think you know guys
who they don't know that [ __ ] who the
the big companies aren't they're not
gonna [ __ ] with it the big boys are too
because I know they're gonna get sued
well they they know that this is just if
you're on the wrong side of things you'd
be [ __ ] mm-hmm what we do good we know
for sure is it's not helpful I was gonna
say yeah vaping is not good for you
whether it's less bad for you than
cigarettes is yeah it's still not good
for you it's fun and when we talk about
vape enough people deal what about when
you won't get vaping is what do you when
you what about vaping weed versus
smoking weed sam issue we don't know how
would assume say miss you man I don't I
don't smoke it anyway you know I don't
do anything no I just do CBD CBD oil do
you do is non psychoactive I don't see I
thought you smoked weed in the war
now never mind what I just do CBD I
could get because they relaxed me
without yeah I don't know I don't I I
doesn't it gets in the video as
non-psychoactive I'm high if I smoke
weed tonight
even at night I wake up the next day a
little cloudy I'm not as sharp hmm sharp
personally people who when I see young
people and I look we can be good for
certain people when I see young people
who are trying to get somewhere in there
smoking weed all the time
during the day I I don't care what
anybody says I don't think that's a good
I don't think that's gonna be very good
for your progress sometimes people
suffer from anxiety and it can help them
but I just feel like overall average if
I had them you know I I think if you're
if you're going for something and you
want to be successful smoking weed in
the morning it's well can we during the
day probably not it's not gonna be
helpful to you I don't care what anybody
says what do you think I don't know it
depends if you need if you don't know I
don't know yeah I would say not to but
some people were you talking about dude
it's the only way I get by yeah some
people that's see how we can get by you
know but yeah in general I would say
it's smoking anything's not gonna be
good yeah well it's vape weed cigarettes
now a little Elijah Craig 18 euro okay
if you want to do a couple shots so
people said but actually you know liquor
kills more people than cigarettes or
[ __ ] we yeah I'm at was judging last
night's way worse free than babe how
about this with my buddy my buddy goes
to the doctor he's older they look in
his mouth daily you might have throat or
mouth cancer and because I don't smoke
and they go yeah but do you drink he
goes every day he goes
drink it freaky yeah he's always
drinking five bottles of wine but the
point is that the point is is that
alcohol actually is the culprit they
look at when you have mouth I'll do that
close it's so terrible for you it's bad
bladder cancer all those weird cancers
first thing they do is they go do you
smoke
I'm 52 and I go no negai we're not gonna
really it's almost never with unless you
but like I'm smoking yeah if you smoke
they touch you for bladder cancer all
kinds of weird [ __ ] you're getting
you're so when you smoke you actually
are more likely get other cancers a lot
of times according to my doctor then
lung cancer
so when you're younger who's there a
smoker you're gonna get you're gonna get
they'll check you for this it's very
common to get other cancers and lung
cancer I thought lung cancer was the
number one thing you get now no you're
more likely to get these other weird
things that matter the answer yeah what
else you doing I think that's what I was
told me tell you this right now yeah
yeah yeah yeah watch your tongue oh good
what's gonna happen what are you gonna
do use some of that boxing you've been
doing
[Laughter]